hello everybody and welcome to episode
number five of my road to one bill
series today uh we're starting off by
heading to Za for the first time ever
which is pretty exciting uh the reason
we're doing this is we want to unlock
the farming patch here uh which requires
you to go to Za and I'll have to get 25
construction I think um but yeah pretty
excited for this episode and let's get
started hold up got a maze random all
right okay let's do this trying to get
under 70% or above 70% sorry okay so
we're going to finish about 65% so not
too bad definitely could have gone a
little bit better
but we kind of got lost so let's see
what we get anyway uh we ended up
getting ah we got a RAR seed that's
pretty good and a bunch of arrows so I
couldn't have asked for too much more
okay so to put my house in K you need 25
construction and the reason I need that
of course is to cuz it's near the
farming patch uh every other thing else
takes way too high level to use so um to
teleport there anyway so we're going to
use the house teleport and so for that
we need 25 construction we also need a
house um so we have to get a house first
uh 1,000 coins for start our house which
seems pretty reasonable to
me and um there we go so let's do the
teleport and we're in our house so we
will start the construction grind all
right there's level five construction we
are just making these shitty
chairs uh really quick and there's level
10 construction we're on to building
bookcases now I'm still very quick skill
okay there's AEV 15 construction uh
we're almost out of nails hopefully we
don't run out before 25 okay there's 20
construction we're now making
workbenches I believe uh it's a little
bit quicker I guess um but uses up the
planks a lot quicker okay we're just
about to hit 25 construction although we
break so many of these [__]
nails and there it is level 25
construction now we can have our house
in Za and do a five um Patch Farm Run
Okay so we're just hit the real estate
agent again and we're just about to
quickly move our our host Ken uh
hopefully we don't need anything else
and uh yeah we're good we got our host
in Za so let's do the teleport and just
for the first time for fun so that is
probably our most convenient teleport in
Za everything else requires you to kill
some of the monsters there our highest
layer level or something like that here
we are actually pretty close to the
patch you can see probably it takes 5 or
10 seconds to run there and um to go to
home teleport we do need a couple more
magic levels or maybe just one um but
we're just going to train out the cester
demon for a minute here um he doesn't
have a chance okay we're just about to
hit 40 magic so we now can use the home
teleport spell so we don't have to waste
all the money on the teleport tabs we
would like to get to level 45 to do the
Camelot teleport as well uh but we might
get that a little bit later okay there's
40 magic so yeah kind of on our way on
the magic levels okay we're actually
just about to hit 40 agility um we've
been doing this for our course for quite
a while but there we go 40 agility it is
now we can finally move on to the
canifis course uh which gives you a lot
more marks per hour which is nice so I
actually just noticed I have 30 marks of
Grace so I can actually finally buy my
first graceful set so we're going to go
for the gloves uh first because the
boots we might still get the boots of
lightness and the gloves is the only
other thing we can
afford um they reduce think 3 kg or
something 2 kg I don't know I think it's
supposed to be three so I'm a little
confused by that but anyway we got our
first piece of graceful which is cool
and yeah now we're on to the canifis
course we're going to stay here probably
to level 60 agility cuz we were in it
more for the um marks of Grace so I know
there's other courses with better
experience but we're mainly looking for
the weight reduction equipment so we're
going to stay here cuz it does provide
the best marks of Grace prow I believe
okay we're just doing the Canabis course
we're about to hit Level 45 agility um
it's definitely quicker but it's not the
quickest experience I've ever gotten but
um you know there's 45
agility um got a decent amount of marks
of Grace actually from here it's
definitely noticeably quicker we have 13
in the inventory and we have another 177
in the bank um but I think we're going
to save up 40 for the graceful Cape
because it definitely looks the coolest
and um again we might get the boots of
lightness at some point okay so we just
got another 10 marks of Grace that puts
us at 40 uh which is actually just
enough enough for the cape um so again
if you don't know where the graceful
person is you have to go to
borp however you pronounce that and you
just run down to this little bar here
and then there's a trap door and then
you go down it and then there's a couple
people as well as a very useful fire
down here um but Grace is just kind kind
of on the southern end of it I guess
just over by the uh equipment shop over
there uh so we're going to trade her and
buy one of the graceful capes which is
definitely the most fashionable one um
40 coins or marks whatever perfect so we
got the cape that's exciting looks cool
and we have a bit more weight reduction
finally down to minus 6 kg which is
actually pretty useful in its own we
definitely want to grind out the full
set eventually
though okay so we actually just finished
up another 40 seeds we're just finishing
our last run which actually is in Ken
which is kind of nice uh so you can see
it really did not take very long to run
down here probably only 10 seconds so
it's actually pretty close and we're
just going to finish up our last run and
someone told me that you can actually
note the rars by using on tool
leprechaun apparently you can also Story
tools there so it's crazy did not know
all this [__] but I'm glad you guys told
me so I can be a little more efficient
doing this now uh but yeah we'll head
back to the Grand exchange and sell off
the herbs okay so in total we actually
got 22 22 sorry 244 rars so that that
run was definitely a lot better than the
last one we got 44 rars more than last
time I think this is probably a little
above average but still very nice see
what we can actually sell them back for
sell them for
7150 uh which will get us probably like
1,700 or 1800k so quite a lot of money
we bought these all for 800k so keep
that in mind we got 1 mil in profit okay
there 50 agility we finally got it um we
have the foul course available we're
definitely not going to do it we're just
going to grind out here for some more
marks of Grace and at 60 we'll head to
the Sears course okay so we actually
grinded out another 40 marks of Grace um
and I think we're actually going to buy
the graceful set or so the graceful
boots uh we were going to not buy that
and just see if we got the boots of
lightness but we just want the no weight
reduction now we need 40 range for
Temple of iov and while I think I might
go train my range soon um I just want
the rate reduction now so down to like
minus 12 or something um so pretty nice
um and look all our grimy rard sold so
we'll definitely go claim that money
right now okay all the grimy renards
have sold and we sold them again for 1.7
mil so that's about 1 mil in profit
which is insane takes me about probably
roughly 2 days to farm um 40 rars so not
too long honestly we're going to go
ahead and buy another 40 RAR seeds right
now I can see exactly how much it cost
me 846k so actually closer than now 00k
in profit but I mean still that's so
still very good for only playing 10
minutes a day to get that okay so we're
going to start by training our range
actually we decided to start that now so
maybe we shouldn't have bought the
graceful boots but um we're going to
whack these cows with these iron knives
for a while and yeah get some range
levels another maze random this time we
only got 60% reward uh but considering
how much we [__] up at the beginning
of this maze I'm surprised we even got
that and we got complete [__] okay so
we're about hit another range level I it
just hurts me to see all these iron
knives on the ground so we're going to
go for the AAS accumulator pretty soon
but there's 20 range um pretty quick
with these iron knives okay so we're
just going to train at chaos Druids um
because you get the herb drops not too
bad but yeah there is 25 range pretty
quick going so far we just got to get
five one levels pretty much so I'm at
minars now cuz some [__] douche came
in then one shot me with a granite Maul
so we uh left there cuz that was no fun
so we came here to minars and yeah
there's 30 range so we're we're going to
just leave at that for now cuz that is
one of the requirements for the animal
magnetism Quest so another requirement
is um I need 18 Slayer so we're going to
start our first task which is ice
Warriors which is actually not too bad
we'll have to see how I far against them
not sure how strong they are uh this is
actually a pretty decent task um they
have a good amount of HP but they don't
actually deal too much damage to me I'm
drinking super attacks and super
strengths uh actually we just hit his
strength level there and The Slayer
level so it's going to go pretty quick
um and yeah actually pretty good first
task to be honest
all right we hit 10 slay um we only
really killed 10 of these things so far
so it's pretty quick got 78 left on the
task still okay so we're just about to
hit 15 Slayer I think uh oh [__] we're
already at 18 wow that was so quick um
but we still have 30 ice Warriors left
on the task so we'll probably go ahead
and kill all these and just see what
Slayer level we end up with okay so we
finished our task of ice Warriors um got
us 22 Slayer now we have crawling hands
which is pretty awful um but I think
that's we're going to call it for today
guys I hope you enjoyed the episode we
got a good amount of progress done it's
a bit of a shorter one though still and
yeah if you're enjoying the series
please leave the series a like uh it's
been really awesome with the amount of
interaction and I will see you guys in
episode number
[Music]
six